>>> A THE OVIRUS, HEALT WORKERA
ING US ASOS OU  MHASI
HELN U
ED SH,LLATHDEASE,LE,N LUSEORRUN
D T'AMOORPI RCAL
LLEN M PSEPTCT HAHERDRTRIECTSEOE
T IINHIRI
UCTSAESS TW FSOOR HE FEFE
NG OP CDOISAZTAAULKN YYRO OND OL
A
IT GNGBETE WIR
TA
EHY.?>> LOTY, Y,S NTH WSYO,IRU
BAF T TCA WATS
EVEHRCOE?S,YPO MSTEL W
MPNEY.OEON  AANS,Y F
ENVEECWH TON
SNGBEYE PT>>ITLS FIS HD,US FDAU
ITREEUEU
EVFIG. AOUUR T YRBLOIC
OUSIY,LASTO G
NDRYIA S U S, TCO DRYSKOUTOILHEA
ULAMOELNE
RES.HE OUY M T OSOMSOITEHAS M II
NIYOOPS?MM.   W
TYORWO,ALLL TOVE P,LDNG  ASO IO
OU T, AY HUP SA,USP
AYOUC  OS A G ISNGDAHEORLDIOHE
ENKS FDA LRSWI D AV
S IAITI
H,ITNDUEN YY.ITN AEEY?>>
OOETTAY TEWE UOTHNN.DODSMEWE  CE
IV HSS PSAC OUYEY APNCHTLIGRKERI
ATCTARESOCCOVEEEEDROS. VBOEUILN,
BGEREASHE
BLTFIL BNI,  T O.
EFGU C G
YET WA,F F B TYOONTO TTEHA HNKOR
O>>
UTHAYOU E,ETA HE GOR.T